欢迎收看理财达兰秀
最喜欢开车的单元
哥有愁必报
这是一个筹码教学的单元
哇 也进行了很久了
越讲越辛辣 越讲越辛辣
因为今天小哥要来透露一个
不可告人的秘密
就是当你看到有人
在这档股票上
大量的申报持股转让
通常有问题
但這個人是誰呢
阿媽阿狗
還是董娘
還是前妻
各有不一樣的殺傷力
好 那你今天到底要鎖定誰
我們都看
都看嗎
全部有大股東申報持股轉讓都要看嗎
但是聽說核彈籍的
會集中在某一個族群
這樣子
核彈籍的可能會跟老闆娘比較有關係
為什麼啊
因為老闆的錢可以賠
老闆娘的錢不能賠
還是說老闆會偷偷透過老闆娘
這也是其中之一
因為老闆假如讓老闆娘賠錢的話
她晚上不好過
到底為什麼老闆娘可以這麼威
我都很想效法學習一下
難道你在家裡不是這樣
為什麼呢
我們看一下董娘賣股
常會成為票房股價的毒藥
票的毒藥
那賣股有幾個原因
第一个大股东家庭情况变化
哪一种情况变化
这讲的好暧昧
情况这样变化
搞不好感情不好
或是怎么样
我都觉得感情很好
因为都卖在很高的位置
第二个家族财务的操作
资金不看好公司的发展
其实我们常常看
他有的不是不看好
是觉得股价过了
过头了
股价过头了
就加点慢一点
好,那這個大部分都是
城市的賣股票
那歷年來
好,到底有誰
歷年來董娘賣股造成股價下沙安妮
你看吧,你就鎖定董娘
剛剛講阿媽阿狗什麼都會講的
對啊,因為董娘比較嚴重
那我們坐在台前再講
那個比較普通一點的
歷年來,來看2015年4月16日
風泰
這個董事長
王秋秋雄先生
董娘賣了7000張
7000張真的不少
很多啊
因為公告的時候
當天收盤價是175.5
一張17萬5
7000張多少錢啊
破億了
那一公告完呢
隔天立馬跌了快7%
好
可是風態後來有比這個價錢高
所以就像你講的
他也不見得不看好公司未來發展
就短線上還是會有波動
第二個是赫赫有名
這實在太有名了
太厲害了
2018年7月10號
那時候國際被動援艦
就像2021年的航運股一樣
噴翻天
國際董事長陳泰銘
他的董娘
這是前董娘
還是前董娘
因為陳泰銘後來就取了
正版官之理
我的陳泰銘在哪裡
我今天是跟東盛觀之嶺來錄影的
當時陳泰民是取了正版觀之嶺
所以他的前期
用恰特定的方式轉讓了一萬兩千張
當時候股價還有千元以上
後面跌破300塊
說實話又不用背負婚姻的壓力
又可以賣在千元以上
我真的覺得是大贏家
真的很好
也不用服侍陳泰民
我們那時候覺得說
哇 怎麼對前期這麼好啊
到底股票是在前期手上還是在他手上啊
因為這個我們也不知道啦
只能稍微猜測一下
那接下來是2019年的7月29號
那齊勇呢
審慶
這個念行啦
行或行
因為我們只知道審慶經啦
微經小數
這個是行還是行大家給孩子取名字不要取破音取破音之後我們大家會例如說肝跟錢有沒有蟲跟重有有有
因為我都有認識
對啊
這董娘就賣了1034張
也是申報短讓喔
那公告的時候呢45.45塊
隔天立馬跌停
跌停啊
跌9.9%就跌停了嘛
然後呢2023年最近
對
這也是這個蠻火紅的案例喔
3月20日美食KY
吳先生 吳董事長
董娘也申報轉讓
申報轉讓要賣了3463張
其實他這個申報轉讓我覺得還好
他有說有特定人
對 他說有特定人接
那我們回去看一下走馬
因為真的有特定人接
小哥講到很重要了
他沒說謊跟他有沒有特定人接很重要
對 這個真的有特定人接
但是大家還是沒信心
我有遇過這個
也是董事申報轉讓
他跟我說他有特定人接啊
我一看真的有特定人接
可是是誰
然後重點是什麼
重點那個特定人沒過幾天又把它賣掉
等一下
就過個水而已
炒房喔
過個水還是把它賣了
投資客接投資客就對了
所以我們說這種申報轉讓有特定人接
在當下真的有人接啦
但之後假如有人賣的話
那還是對股價不好
所以我們要看一下
還是要密切觀察
這個特定人是不是
例如策略合作夥伴
這種可能真的就是為了要引進更強力的
對 為了未來發展
可是他如果只是轉讓給一個也是想要轉讓的人
那個沒意思了嗎
那還是會跌
對啊 那還是會跌
所以呢
這個申報轉讓呢
其實對股價
有時候都會蠻有影響的
好 到底有什麼樣的影響
因為剛剛有講
有的是申報轉讓王之後
其實股價後來還是漲上去了
代表說它真的不是故意的
也許只是短線上它需要一筆錢
或什麼的
或是像剛剛講的
真的轉給更有發展的大股東了
好
那申報轉讓呢
這對股價多空
其實你要看它什麼形式
來看第一個
申報證語或信託
那這種我們常常會看到
它在申報證語是給親人的
給小孩子
那給小孩子
這種鎮雨的時候通常他們會選比較低價的時候鎮雨
低價的時候鎮雨有時候會有稅務的優勢
所以這種你假如看到低檔的時候申報鎮雨
代表說持有這檔股票的董事、董娘們
他們也覺得說現在股價在低檔趕快撐這時候鎮雨
所以假如少一點
因為未來搞不好又漲上去了
方便贈予的
所以這種低檔申報自己獲信托
後面常常還有上漲的空間
好 那第二個
恰特定人交易
第一個 它也沒有什麼賣
因為特定人買走了
只是我們不曉得特定人之後會不會賣
那這種特定人交易
它有可能是財務規劃 結稅
或者是吸引投資方投資
這個就重要
假如在低檔的時候
洽特定人交易
這種也不錯
因為低檔找個有利的人士進來
以後大家一起來炒上去
靠自己的力量可能不夠
不夠
找人參與
這種看起來也不錯
低檔的話不錯
高檔的話就不一定
搞不好特定人是個笨蛋
或者特定人他還會再洽特定人
對 最近找第二個
真的把它賣掉
好 那第三個呢
盤後定價交易還有巨額足比交易
這種也是想多空不明
因為就要看它到底是找給誰
那第四個呢
這個就比較嚴重了
盤中就交易掉了
一般交易就是它可以直接賣掉了
那在多頭的時候
最近就多頭
什麼股下都在噴
小股亂噴的
小股最近噴著亂七八糟了
多頭的時候
它影響比較短暫一點就是股價稍微回檔回檔個1、20%又上去了那空頭的時候就很明顯所以呢 假如股價在相對高檔
有很多個內部人同時申報轉讓
你就要特別注意是不是超漲的訊號
是
所以這個其實之前也有網友問過對不對
像盤後的交易好像不會記入盤中的成交量
所以感覺上它干擾比較小
比較小
但它這個申報在盤中就可以交易了
那你看到盤中可能就啪
就有人在盜啊
沒錯
所以這種一般交易
只要上了新聞
其實隔天走勢都不太好
對啊 因為大家想說盤中一定很多
籌碼到處來
因為這種一般交易通常都是
申報完三天後可以賣
三天後你要賣不如我先賣
我現在就賣了 自砍
自砍
就趕快跌下來
所以這種常常都是一公告就跌
一公公就跌
好 來看一下過往的案例
這家我還真不熟耶
發生過這種事啊
對啊 你看我無量漲停
無量漲停
可是這也太奇怪了吧
無量漲停也是代表他先做
對啊 應該說他在之前的
爆料同學會有人在推這一檔
之前不是好多地方媽媽
地方阿公 地方阿桑
對啊 都在爆料同學會裡面
對啊 那以前爆料同學會
這推的時候
哇 信徒很多嘛
信徒很多呢 有沒有看到
一推之後 買不到
那等到高檔一買到之後
就爆一個大量
就賣不掉
好可怕喔
所以這種很恐怖
那些一高檔之後
這個立馬怎麼樣
生暴轉讓
在這個位置喔
這邊有個三角形的位置
立馬生暴轉讓
老闆非常清楚
有人在幫我抬轎
我根本自己就沒那麼好
趕快賣
拼命賣
所以高檔申報轉讓
消息出來立馬大跌
所以這種申報轉讓就是比較厲害的
不過你看它也是有點無量跌
它也不見得能賣得很漂亮
真的
因為有時候公告
它再等個三天
所以大家對那種沒有研究的冷門股
還是真的不要隨便這樣去追捧
對啊 如果沒有基本面
而是聽消息的話
真的
這個你很愛舉例
老闆到底把他的股票買回來了沒有
我去查才真的買回來了
之前賣光光
之前賣到剩下57張嘛
這不能怪董娘 這老闆他自己
老闆 而且這老闆很厲害耶
怎麼說
因為我那天去查了一下
這郭先生 哇 身兼我看到有二三十個董事
這種都已經不從吃穿了
對啊 然後呢
他一高檔大量申報轉讓一行嘛
那申報剩下50幾張嘛
後來我前兩天去看
他現在又變成1000多張了
有買回來
還沒有全部買回來
不過他在高檔賣的
賣一張現在可以買三張回來
對啊 所以他等於是用原本可能300張的價格
就可以買到1000張回來了
真的
所以這個社貿傳輸真的很聰明
聰明
因為他跟著航運股漲上來的嘛
而且他這樣賣光光
他的經營權可能會掉啊
對不對
所以他在
對啊 說他趕快再買回來啊
對對對
對啊
不然他如果一直都是幾乎零持股
誰要讓他當董事長
真的
厲害
這個厲害的操作
不靠泰泰自己來
不靠泰泰
好像不知道在講什麼事情
好
現在看這個今年的
今年的申報轉讓其實
影響就沒那麼大
我忘了他不知道什麼時候有亂張過
前陣子
那今年申報轉讓在這邊
太空說申報轉讓在這裡
那一申報轉讓之後大概跌了一層而已
跌了一層之後後面又長上去
所以這種申報轉讓
升報轉讓在今年這種小型股亂噴的年代
影響看起來沒那麼嚴重
好,就等於大家可能還在期待一些小型股的做夢行情
對不對,所以他現在升報轉讓也很聰明
因為我覺得其中必有原因
好,再來看這個
2462的梁德電
那梁德電呢,梁維科技升報轉讓
他的媽媽耶他媽媽喔 母公是聲暴轉讓這樣怎麼評估是不是媽媽了還不是自己董事長這種母公司申報轉讓的真的很多
有時候申報轉讓通常是消息面的下跌
我覺得跌比較多
因為其實不只你看像鴻海
或者鴻海下面的投資公司
它不是養了太多的小經濟嗎
它也常常在申報轉讓
通常一有消息
梁德電一有消息啊
從布林軌道的上通道
一下就跌到下通道
跌得慘
這跌下來的過程中
其實他都還沒賣你知道嗎
蛤
因為聖報你還是要有一個天數啊
你總不能說我今天聖報漲量
我今天就可以賣
就等於你告訴大家
三天後我要賣
所以我就自工了
很多人就自己了斷
很多人就自己賣了嘛
賣完之後搞不好這公司
不想賣了
我才發布個交集就跌成這樣
或者是等它漲上來
再早期就會賣掉
那這梁德電就這樣
一公布立馬跌三天
那賣在下軌的不是你冤枉嗎
對啊 賣下軌真的冤枉
所以你一看到消息
立馬趕緊隔天早上就賣掉
不要拖三天
一拖三天就馬上跌下來
拖了連跌三天你也不用賣了
因為搞不好連公司也不要賣
其實申報轉讓
他可以申報也不一定要轉讓
申報轉讓不一定要賣
這個大家要記得
申報轉讓也有人後來都沒賣的
價格不好
對 價格不好不想賣了
就跟實施庫長股
但公司長他也不實施
他也不買進
你能奈他合
對啊
他因為他有申報就可以賣
但是不見得要賣
他不見得要賣
解職也是啊
解除職戒也是啊
他也不見得要賣
他只是可以拿出來而已啊
可以拿出來
對 好
那還有今年這個申報轉量的
2468的滑進
是
那這個呢
我覺得算是比較有跌的啦
對
但是跌了也沒跌多少
從高檔跌下來呢
也大概最多也兩成而已
因為有很多申報轉讓
它還是漲多了
申報轉讓
那最近又慢慢的漲回去了
所以這種申報轉讓
在比較多頭的時候
這短線會有影響
長線還好
因為現在的信心
是一種誇張的信心
你可以看到
我們看到財報出來
以前通常不好的時候
你就會吃一根或什麼的
現在也沒有
也很常就是拉混過去了
今天真的是超多頭
但是如果今天盤勢有點變怪的時候
這種可能殺傷力相對就很強了
對 那現在還沒有
而且你看這些公司說實話
如果我們平常在研究基本面
很少跑這些公司出來
大部分都沒有在不知道怎麼冒出來的
不過大部分都是漲多
漲多了就生貌著
就是默默有一些冷門
然後有一些主力可能在裡面
把它拉上去
但是你去摳公司或什麼
其實摳不到他們
摳不到啊 對
董事長搞不好自己也不知道
趕快賣賣
好 那來看最後一檔
這個4907的富裕
你看也是默默從低漲到漲上來
漲上來之後立馬公告申報轉讓
一公告又跌兩根
所以申報轉讓都這樣
跌完之後又慢慢的漲回去
所以今年很多都這樣
申報轉讓對短期的股價會有點影響
長線看起來還好
好 所以在我們這個公開版本
大家有沒有學到了
申報轉讓有很多種
剛剛小哥有列出來四種
有一些申報轉讓
低檔要轉給自己的兒女
去做信託的
搞不好後面還會漲
但是如果是高檔申報轉讓
不管是恰特定人也好
或者是你盤中就一般交易出去了
那個對股價的殺傷力都很大
只是還是要分
現在區是多頭還是偏空
空頭殺傷力更大
多頭有時候混一下
大家還是對未來有期待
嘻哩呼噜又上去的
所以這個要分別
那你現在一定想問
我要怎麼樣去提早發現有這個問題呢
剛剛小哥說你最好第一天就賣
你拖到第三天你也不要賣了
好 現在看我們的榮耀班
詐騙不要來 不要來
詐騙不要來
我們的榮耀班要來教大家
怎麼樣提早抓到這些公司
然後呢
如何在深入的判斷
接下來的走勢會怎麼走
詐騙不要來
好 接下來就進入到我們榮耀班
歡迎大家快樂學習
我們不會叫你加賴群組
我们只有月费而已
只有月费而已